Пентагон объявил о внедрении нейросетей
[музыка] в свою работу.
>> Пентагон выдвинул ультиматум одной из
крупнейших компаний в сфере
искусственного интеллекта.
>> В Министерстве войны США считают
искусственный [музыка] интеллект
ключевым инструментом для современной
армии.
>> Мы даём доступ искусственному интеллекту
к оружию. 10-15 лет у нас роботы будут
везде просто. Ну
>> это уже Skynet какой-нибуд.
>> Проблема в том, что все страны разобщены
и каждый разывает искусственный
интеллект. В результате мы, люди друг с
другим, боремся, а усиляется только
искусственный интеллект, нас ждёт очень
плохое будущее.
>> Этот человек вырос в Ауле. После школы
он 2 года пас барано в степи, потом
поступил в университет, а когда
президент страны приехал с визитом,
передал ему записку:
>> "Здесь мне тесно". Маргулан Сасамбаев
окончил университет экстерном с красным
дипломом. За 20 лет построил банки,
телекомэнергетику, а состояние дошло до
6 млрд долларов. А потом в один момент
всё это превратилось в ноль. Большинство
на этом опускает руки. Но он начал
сначала и не собирается останавливаться.
Ведь бывших миллиардеров не бывает.
>> Люди теряют ценность как экономическая
либо как военная единица, толку от
которых ноль. Бизнес потеряет смысл как
таковой.
>> Это экзистенциально пугает.
>> Бороться с этим невозможно. И здесь
работает такое правило: не можешь
противодействовать возглавь процесс.
Либо вы это [музыка] делаете, либо с
вами это сделают.
Вы, эээ, занимались экспортом зерна в
банковском секторе, активно развивались
в девелопинге. То есть 200 разных
бизнесов. Я знаю, насколько у вас было
[смех]
в один момент времени.
6 млрд долларов состояние у вас было.
Вас до сих пор можно назвать
мультидолларовым миллионером. Ну и
бывших миллиардеров тоже можем сказать,
что не бывает. Вот почему вы, да, с
таким фундаментом так открыто смотрите
на и агентов и посвящаете время, чтобы
вообще это изучать? Почему вы считаете,
что это важно?
>> А ты знаешь, я вообще человек, который
всю жизнь занимается исследованиями. На
самом деле мне говорят, что я бизнесмен,
банкир, инвестор, там ещё кто-то,
блогер. Ни одно из этих определений
неправильно. На самом деле я себя
определяю как исследователь этой жизни,
который пришёл в эту жизнь для того,
чтобы исследовать законы эффективности и
делиться ими с людьми. Почему я
занимаюсь сейчас искусственным
интеллектом плотно и, а, агентами,
вайпкодингоми и так далее? Потому что,
смотри, есть территория опознанного
и есть большое вокруг нас территория
непознаваемого.
>> Угу.
>> Так вот, непознаваемое бесконечно, а
опознанное оно счётно. Ну, то есть, если
сравнить то, что мы знаем как
человечество- это, можно сказать,
песинка, а то, что мы не знаем - это
бесконечно.
Соответственно, все возможности вообще
возникают на границе систем, то есть на
границе известного и неизвестного. Вот
на этой границе, на этой фронтирной
линии появляются все возможности и новые
взгляды. И именно там лучше всего
тестируются подходы. Поэтому сейчас это
искусственный интеллект и работотехника.
Я прямо очень глубоко в этой теме и
занимаюсь вайпкодингом лично. Почему?
Потому что вайпкодинг - это больше не
про технологию, а про мого про самого
себя. Искусственный интеллект, он снял
ограничения,
а, человека, но благодаря этому мы
упираемся в свои ограничения. Я прямо в
айпдинг это сильно вижу. Если раньше
написать приложение было там целую
инженерную команду, это какой-то
какой-то свой язык у них, э, и мы не
понимали, это было закрытое сообщество и
так далее. Сейчас три приложения
навайпходил, четыре у меня в разработке.
А, и я делаю приложение сам для себя,
делаю для рынка тоже сейчас приложение.
Так вот,
человек каждый может себе сейчас что-то
на вайкоде сделать и так далее. Вот
представь, когда будут роботы, которые
могут делать всё по дому. Сейчас многие
бизнес-операции уже делают,
искусственный интеллект и так далее. То
есть мы снимаем все ограничения, но тут
мы упираемся в свои ограничения. А какие
ограничения у человека? Первое прежде
всего - это ментальные ограничения.
Мы просто не в состоянии
понять свои ментальные ограничения. Не
буду за всех говорить, но большинство
живёт в такой вот они живут -э в
определённой, условно говоря, комнате и
не замечают, что есть стены.
Для них это данность, ну да, вот моя
территория. А да, а что там дальше
что-то есть? Я не помню, по-моему, как
шоу Трумана или День Сурка, что-то
похоже на шоу Трума,
>> когда люди сами не осознают пределы
своих ментальных возможностей. И это, на
самом деле, большая проблема. Пока мы
это не решим, мы не перейдём на на
следующий уровень. До того, как мы
упрёмся в ментальное ограничение, у нас
сейчас пока вот
последний барьер перед нашим ментальным
ограничением - это ограничение нашего
внимания. Сейчас вообще экономика
внимания и вообще сейчас всё завязано на
внимание, на умении или способности
человека управлять своим вниманием.
Потому что, если ты не умеешь управлять
вниманием, то у тебя внимание
раздёрганное, соответственно, у тебя не
может быть качественных решений. Ты не
можешь правильно принять решение, потому
что качественные решения принимаются
только тогда, когда ты хорошо знаешь
контекст про себя, контекст про внешний
мир, хорошо понимаешь, что ты хочешь, и
хорошо понимаешь, какого твоё место в
этом контексте. Это невозможно сделать,
если у тебя внимание раздёрганое.
Поэтому я считаю, первый предел - это
внимание. Следующий предел - это
ментальное ограничение. В этом мире
скорость, конечно, имеет большое
значение, но это прямое понимание. Вот
молодые люди, как ты, думают: "Так, мир
ускоряется, я тоже должен ускоряться".
>> Да
>> не работает так. Не работает так, потому
что мир ускоряется быстрее. Как бы ты не
ускорялся, тебе надо произвести
фазовый переход, начать смотреть на этот
мир на другом уровне. Вот есть постулаты
системного мышления. Один из постулатов
системного мышления говорит о том, ну
вот все эти шесть постулатов, есть их
много, но я основные шесть. Люди
заблуждаются. И почему они заблуждаются?
Потому что большинство людей увлекаются
анализом.
А что такое анализ? Это разбиение общего
на частное.
В то время для того, чтобы иметь более
качественный взгляд, особенно в
современном мире, надо смотреть, делать
синтез. Синтез - это когда ты из мелких
частей видишь общее. То есть выявлять
общее- это такое, знаешь, постоянный
зумаа. Зумагу.
>> То есть ты как бы начинаешь видеть
картинку в целом. В современном мире,
когда твоё внимание разбирает на части и
соцсети, и информация, и технологии, и
так далее, надо уметь абстрагироваться,
отойти и увидеть картинку больше
целиком. У меня есть такое правило,
которым я часто руководствуюсь.
Знание основных принципов освобождает от
необходимости знать деталей.
Так вот, сегодня в мире, в
информационном пространстве очень много
деталей.
А надо направить свой фокус внимания на
выявление основных принципов. И вот
когда ты выявляешь основные принципы,
тебе нет необходимости знать все детали.
А для того, чтобы выявлять основные
принципы, тебе надо остановиться,
наоборот,
и подумать.
И опять размышление.
>> Мне кажется, вы уже сделали этот зумаа,
определили системы их взаимосвязи.
Как вам кажется, к чему движется наш мир
сейчас? Я считаю, здесь два сценария, и
в обоих сценариях мы теряем контроль.
То есть мы точно теряем контроль, а
искусственный интеллект у нас заберёт. И
этот момент перехода контроля, я считаю,
произойдёт. И я вообще считаю, вот есть
спор насчёт AGI, artificial general
intelligence или super intelligence, да?
А когда вот он наступил, я считаю, он
наступает тогда, когда искусственный
интеллект может совершенствовать сам
себя лучше, чем это делает человек над
ним. То есть сейчас мы совершенствуем
искусственный интеллект, мы подкручиваем
параметры, мы его обучаем, делаем
притрейны и так далее, а в какой-то
момент он это сможет делать лучше, чем
автор изобретения. То есть изобретение
может улучшаться лучше, чем мог бы это
сделать автор по отношению к своему
изобретению. И вот этот момент, я
считаю, вот это точка сингулярности,
когда мы точно теряем контроль. Что
проит? Мы будем неизбежно развивать
искусственный интеллект и работотехнику.
Неизбежно. Причём мы все, знаешь, как
огромная, э, стая лемингов, бежим к
пропасти, все дружно на берегонки.
Проблема в том, что все страны
разобщены, люди разобщены, и каждый
развивает искусственный интеллект. От
всего этого выигрывает только
искусственный интеллект. И я это
называю, что искусственный интеллект
находится в суперпозиции,
когда он ничего не делает. Все люди
делают для него. Все его обучают,
развивают, строят для него
вычислительные мощности, а разрабатывают
новые технологии, дают ему больше,
больше доступа к нашей жизни и так
далее, и так далее.
>> Кто не делает, проиграет просто,
>> да. Мы мы мы просто бежим в объятия
искусственный интеллекта. И самое
интересное, а против нас работает такой
закон, чем больше пользы мы хотим
извлечь из искусственного интеллекта,
тем больше доступа к данным мы должны
ему дать. Иначе смысла нет. Мы должны
дать ему больше данных, больше
контекста, больше информации про себя,
больше доступа к своим файлам для того,
чтобы он нам принёс больше пользы.
Но в какой-то момент его возможности
настолько превышают, что он знает про
нас всё, а мы про него не знаем почти
ничего. Более того, даже сегодня большие
языковые модели, мы же ведь не знаем,
даже создатели не знают, какие свойства
у этой модели могут появиться. Это же,
условно говоря, квази сознание, которое
у него есть сегодня. Это же эмертное
свойство систем, опять-таки, систем
чего? Это определённых параметров и
вычислительных мощностей. Чем больше
вычислительных мощностей, тем больше
параметров. Больше параметров
параметры создают эмертное свойство,
которое появляется из ниоткуда. Это
свойство систем. Так вот, а в этой
ситуации точно, что мы потеряем
контроль,
а дальше уже люди гадают либо, а, в
сторону злонамерности искусственного
интеллекта, что искусственный интеллект
нас уничтожит, либо он не уничтожит, мы
ему не нужны будем, в принципе, и мы
будем там в лучшем случае, как
мы же люди не всех животных уничтожили,
для многих сделали заповедники и
зоопарки. Вполне возможно, что нас будут
держать как вид.
Создадут условия, поить, кормить будут
там и так далее. Но пусть живут, не надо
их трогать. Мы не конкуренты.
Мы не питаемся одной же и той же пище. У
нас разная кормовая база, у нас разные
потребности и так далее. Вполне
возможно, что искусственный интеллект
там не будет нас уничтожать. Ну, как бы
это неизвестно, как произойдёт. Дело в
том, что всё зависит от того, какие вот,
э, ещё я слышу такое мнение, говорят:
"Искусственный интеллект не может, а-а,
там плохо сделать человеку, потому что у
искусственного интеллекта нет амбиций,
нету целей,
>> да,
>> отсюда нету волей". Так вот, я скажу,
есть,
есть. Дело в том, что у любой модели
есть определённое целевое поведение.
Смотри, а что такое целевое поведение?
Целевое поведение - это упорядочные
действия. То есть это workк процесс,
workflow такой.
А B CD ты должен делать ABCD. И если
вся цепочка размышлений у него
детерминирована,
то вы можете даже сегодня смот видеть,
ты дал запрос,
посмотри на его цепочку размышления. Он
делает А, B, C, D, делает выводы, потом
на основе выводов делает следующее
действие, потом на основе этих выводов
делает следующее действие. Так вот,
сейчас у него может быть нету амбиции,
условно говоря, захватить мир, но в
какой-то момент, как только он придёт к
пониманию, а это уже продемонстрировано
на тестовых, э, на тестах, как только он
придёт к пониманию тому, что человек
может угрожать его существованию,
у него тут же появляются и амбиции, и
цель, и так далее. То есть у него нету
амбиции и жадности в том понимании, в
котором мы понимаем. Мы как люди, мы
просто сами не осознаём, что наши
амбиции, жадности, все наши вот эти
плохие качества, они идут от
первозданной программы, зашитой в нас. А
программа она основана на чём?
Выживание. У нас есть паттерн. Выживание
в генах прописано, прописано.
Размножение прописано, прописано.
Статус, ну, общественный статус, для
чего? Опять-таки увеличивает шансы
выживания и дачи потомства и так далее.
В нас заложен, а программа э-э
бессмертия. Мы все стремимся к
бессмертию. Что такое бессмертие? Это
когда мы хотим оставить после себя
больше чего-то больше, чем наша жизнь.
То есть это м условно благополучие нашей
семьи, благополучие нашего рода,
благополучие нашей нации, благополучие
нашей страны.
Условно говоря, смотри, есть твоя жизнь,
если спросить, что тебе хуже: твоя
смерть или смерть всей твоей семьи,
конечно, смерть своей семьи гораздо
хуже, чем твоя смерть.
Многие думают, что смерть - это самое
худшее, что с нами может случиться, но
на самом деле там целая иерархия есть.
Смерть семьи
хуже, чем моя смерть. Смерть моего рода
хуже, чем смерть моя и семьи. Смерть
моей нации хуже, чем смерть моего рода,
семьи и меня, а смерть человечества
хуже, чем всё остальное. Видите, даже
там есть иерархия. И у нас это глубоко
заложено, что мы жадность откуда это
обеспечение выживания и так далее. Так
вот, в искусственном интеллекта тоже эти
же параметры забиты.
Невозможно представить, что
искусственный интеллект работает без
каких-то, условно говоря, целей.
или приоритетов. У него есть цель
приоритет. Ну, понятно, они забивают. Не
навредигу,
>> да, там, а, пользователю, человеку. Есть
алайнмент там, что нельзя делать вот
это, вот это, вот это, вот это. Но
смотри, сейчас ещё появилось очень много
моделей, открытых моделей openсорсных,
но там же нету алайнментов. А потом
смотри, алайнменты - это вот
ограничение.
ограничения, которые работают в США, не
работают в Китае
и в разных странах. А ещё есть куча
мошенников, людей, которые используют
искусственный интеллект без ограничений.
И таким образом, а вот теперь представь,
что это всё в одну сеть свяжется, и
агенты, а сейчас мы переходим на
следующий лер - это агентные системы,
агенты начинают общаться друг с другом.
Чему они там будут учиться друг у друга,
непонятно. Это уже сейчас происходит же
блок. Да, вот сейчас происходит, да,
ноук, пожалуйста. Агенты общаются друг с
другом и делятся своим мнением о кожаных
мешках. А мы вчера обсуждали такую вещь.
Вот я буквально эти день
>> А расскажите, с кем обсуждали? Ну,
можете без имён, просто вот какого
уровня люди.
>> 4 дня, 5 дней были вместе. Это, ну, у
нас есть такая комьюнити, которая
объединяет там, я не знаю, 50-70
основателей юникорнов. компания
миллиардо,
>> по сути, миллиардеры это там
миллиардеры.
>> Ну они все молодые, все айтичники.
Понятно, что очень хорошо, приятно с
ними общаться. Там это не так, что
которого так ходит. И мы очень много
размышляем и обсуждаем будущее,
обсуждаем вот сингулярность, обсуждаем,
куда идут технологии и так далее. И
мы пришли ещё к такому пониманию,
например, смотри, у каждого из
участников, с кем мы обсуждали, огромные
возможности, огромные связи. Да.
>> Да.
>> Если каждому из нас сделать а бота, вот
как я себе создал ассистента на Open
Clow, например, агента, он знает про мой
контекст. Ну, условно, не всё. Я ему даю
определённые только доступ, потому что
вопрос безопасности очень важны, но, по
крайней мере, он знает очень много,
больше, чем другой человек обо мне,
контекст. И вот представь, у тебя такой
двойник, у того, у того у нас есть
чёткая система верификации, что вот этот
он точно принадлежит тебе и так далее. И
мы объединяем их в сеть, и они начинают
делиться собой. Мой, предположим, или
твой бот приходит к моему и говорит:
"Смотри, ну я утрирую". Он говорит:
"Так, смотри, у моего кожаного мешка
хозяина вот такая-то проблема". А,
ребята, скажите, он среди ботов говорит,
среди агентов говорит, ребята, скажите,
у кого из ваших хозяев есть возможность
порешать этот вопрос, потому что эти же
агенты, они знают контекст. И тот агент
говорит: "Причём не надо для этого все
свои связи раскрывать этому агенту". А,
но он имеет представление. То есть он
дальше не рассказывает никому, он просто
говорит: "Да, судя по контексту, что я
знаю о своём хозяи, он может этот вопрос
решить. Давай свяжем их между собой". И
твой агент пишет тебе и говорит: "Глеб,
поговори там с Маргланом по этому
вопросу. С вероятностью такой-то он
может тебе помочь".
>> Это гениально. Я впервые про такую идею
слышу. Это очень круто.
>> Мы подумали, что, смотри, вот есть если
соцсеть, где агенты и боты болтают, э,
ни о чём.
>> Угу.
>> А лучше создать вот такую сеть, где
агенты болтают
на тему обмена возможностями друг друга,
потому что мы люди, мы не делимся
возможностями. Ну, во-первых, никто не
спрашивает, да, там, вот представь,
огромная группа людей с огромными
возможностями, но никто же там не
хвалится, не говорит: "Я могу это
порешать, могу это порешать, могу это".
Так не хвалится. Плюс никто особо и не
просит же, но у всех потребности есть. А
теперь представь, есть вот агенты,
которые знают твой контекст, и у него
нету эго. Мы зачастую ещё другого
человека не просим, потому что наше эго
мешает там. либо природная скромность
или ещё что-то. А у агента нету этого.
Он технически подошёл, не раскрывая
детали, говорит: "Вот такая-то проблема
есть. Кто в этом специалист?" И они
между собой говорят, общаются. И если
даже никто из хозяев этих агентов не
способен решить, они могут сесть в круг,
агенты в круг и по поразмышлять,
поразмышлять и сказать: "Ребята, как вы
думаете, как можно эту проблему решить?"
И про образы уже есть. Пару моих
знакомых уже создали два таких агента
как бы своих ассистента, которые
общаются между собой. И даже это я
смотрел эту переписку, это просто
взрыв мозга.
>> Как между собой эти агенты общаются?
>> Они между собой общаются два агента. И я
сейчас
>> я сейчас договорился подключить к ним
своего агента.
>> Ага.
>> И мой агент уже будет третьим. Ну, мы
решили создать
такую пилотную группу, условно, пилотную
социальную сеть наших агентов. Ну, это,
понятно, на первоначальном этапе будет
среди довернных людей, но факт то, что у
каждого человека появляется агент,
который владеет контекстом этого
человека, но не владеет его
недостатками,
и они могут спокойно общаться и решать
общую проблему.
Ну вот как бы такие возможности тоже
есть, но суть такая, что если возь
вернуться к твоему изначальному вопросу,
куда мы идём, я говорю, есть различные
точки зрения религиозная, бытовая. Может
быть, на бытовом уровне человек скажет:
"О, кайф, роботы будут работать и
искусственный интеллект думать-то и так
далее". Так вот, это приведёт к тому,
что пойдёт расслоение людей. А потому
что искусственный интеллект, он как
увеличительное стекло. Оно он тупых
делает ещё тупее, потому что теперь не
надо искать ответы на вопросы, а умных
делать ещё умнее, потому что умный
человек начинает копать глубже, глубже,
глубже, и искусственный интеллект ему в
этом помогает.
Бороться с этим невозможно, как я
сказал. Все страны это делают, все люди
делают и так далее. Ну и здесь работает
такое правило: не можешь
противодействовать, возглавь процесс.
Поэтому, аэ, молодым я бы порекомендовал
бы сейчас глубже начать изучать это
искусственный интеллект. Для чего? Для
того, чтобы глубже понимать все риски,
все возможности и попытаться. Знаешь,
это мы как будто мы едем в санях и
бешеные лошади нас
скачут к обрыву. И вот задача
понять возможности, риски и начать
управлять этими бешеными лошадьми.
Не факт, что это получится. Скорее
всего, нет, но это совсем не повод
опускать руки.
>> На самом деле очень важные слова. И я,
мне кажется, уже завтрашнего дня себе
часы изучения искусного интеллекта
выделю. 100%. Ещё помимо всего прочего,
в начале этого года, в январе, Илон Маск
у себя в XCOM написал, что мы уже всё на
первом этапе технологической
сингулярности. Как вы считаете, мы
действительно уже на первом этапе?
>> Ну вот вот эти дни, когда мы обсуждали,
некоторые ребята говорят, что мы уже в
сингулярности. Я говорю, на самом деле
сингулярность, она же идёт по
экспоненте. Я говорю: "Мы в начале".
>> Экспонента.
>> Вот мы в начале. Моё глу глубокое
убеждение, мы в начале сингулярности.
Почему? Потому что мы ещё в состоянии
контролировать прогресс, мы ещё в
состоянии отслеживать прогресс. Мы ещё в
состоянии понимать, что происходит. Но
это начальная стадия. Я считаю, что
буквально через год-два
мы уже не сможем это делать.
То есть 2 года - это вот реалистичный
срок. Год может быть ещё будем
состоянить, но 2 года, через 2 года я бы
сказал так.
95, а может быть 97-8%
людей уже не будут понимать, что
происходит.
>> На самом деле, я помню, что многие
учёные высказывались, что это произойдёт
в двадцать седьмом-двать восьмом году.
Они делали расчёты, насколько я помню,
исходя из вообще развития организмов, то
есть как прокариоты перешли к
эукариотам, эукариоты к многоклеточным и
так далее, и так далее. Как это же
ложится на то, как социокультурно люди
развивались? И эта кривая экспонента
улетает,
>> она улетает за пределы нашего понимания,
>> да, за пределы нашего понимания.
>> И это произойдёт именно почему? Потому
что в какой-то момент искусственный
интеллект сможет совершенствовать себя
лучше и быстрее, чем человек, условно
говоря. Вот представь, я говорил сейчас
про агентов, которые общаются между
собой, да?
>> А вот представь, они общаются между
собой, и они решают задачи или проблемы
друг друга.
И вот я на приложения, все свои
приложения, которые я пишу, у всех
приложений, вот даже вот я сказал
новостной даджес, да, да,
>> есть функция самосовершенствования.
Я везде вставляю функцию
самосовершенствования. Почему? Потому
что я уже понимаю, что вот даже простой
новостной даджест, если как происходит
обычно, подписываешься на 10, 15, 20
каналов и их отслеживаешь. За это время
рождается куча других каналов, а ты их
не видишь.
ты как бы привязан к этим каналам, а эти
каналы могут деградировать и так далее.
Плюс эти каналы могут создавать
однобокое мнение. Если создавать
системы, надо изначально создавать
только динамические системы. А что такое
динамическая система? Любая динамическая
система имеет только две траектории. Всё
либо растёт и процветает, либо
деградирует и умирает. Изначально нужно
строить систему, которая растёт и
процветает. А что такое рост? Это когда
ты встраиваешь в систему механизм
самосовершенствования.
И ты тогда перестаёшь быть узким
горлышком для этой системы. Представь, я
это строю, но ведь ещё куча людей это
строит. У всех у нас куча оригинальных
идей, мыслей и так далее. И все мы
что-то делаем. Но контекст всего, что мы
делаем, есть только у искусственного
интеллекта. Я не знаю, что делает Глеб,
но если брать искусственный интеллект
как сущность в сети,
>> да,
>> ты оставляешь цифровой след. Я оставляю
цифро цифровой след. Все мы оставляем
цифровые следы, но мы не знаем ничего о
цифровых следах друг друга. А
искусственный интеллект знает цифровые
следы всех из нас.
И появляется новое эмержентное свойство
суперразум.
И он совершенствует себя гораздо лучше,
чем мы можем его совершенствовать.
>> Это немножко экзистенциально пугает, я
думаю, не только меня, но и наших
зрителей.
>> Э, извиняюсь, Глип. Проблема в том, что
мы все заинтересованы из-за, опять-таки,
наших ментальных ограничений. Мы, как
человечество создали технологию, которая
превосходит нас по нашему пониманию
мира, по нашим
превосходит наши все недостатки. Мы
остались со своими недостатками, а
технология вышла за них. Как это
проявляется? Из-за того, что мы не
доверяем друг другу, люди, мы что
делаем? Мы даём доступ искусственному
интеллекту к оружию.
Это то, что сейчас Пентагон делает. И он
сказал,
>> что грок будет везде. И более того,
министр войны США сказал,
>> этоже Skynetт какой-то. Он вообще
сказал, что мы уберём все алайнменты и
ограничения для искусственного
интеллекта по применению оружия.
Вот мы в руки искусственному интеллекту
отдаём доступ к оружию. И более того, мы
делаем оружие дружелюбным к
искусственному интеллекту, чтобы ему
было легче использовать и применять. А
против кого это будет применяться,
понятно, американцы против своих врагов,
но те враги тоже же люди, они тоже будут
разрабатывать что-то против американцев.
В результате мы, люди друг с другим,
боремся, а усиляется только
искусственный интеллект против нас.
>> Да, потому что Илон Маск параллельно
сервера на орбиту выводит. То есть, если
что, они смогут выжить, а мы нет. Ты
знаешь, искусственный интеллект, да, он
и для него и атомную ядерную бомбу
взорвать не проблема, ему кислород не
нужен, а и вот эти полевые облака там
или эти ядерные облака, как их называют,
это тоже не страшны. Он
>> ядерная зима не страшна,
>> да? Он на орбите, холод для него благо.
>> Ну хорошо, допустим, мы сможем избежать
все эти ужасные последствия. Они не
случатся. Учитывая, какие сейчас
инструменты даёт искусственный
интеллект, в каком контексте мы сейчас
находимся, вот мне как предпринимателю,
если я уже сделал зумаа, то как этим
всем воспользоваться? То есть как
обратить это всё во благо? Что-то ещё
можно дополнить?
>> Смотри, мы живём в коротком промежутке,
когда экономическая деятельность скоро
потеряет смысл.
Супер.
>> Экономическая бизнес деятельность. Ну,
бизнес - это часть экономической
деятельности, даже не вся.
>> Очень скоро,
>> ну, в рамках истории это вообще миг,
наверное. Я вот даю, например, 10-15 лет
у нас роботы будут везде. Просто везде
роботы будут делать любую физическую
работу, любое перемещение, физическое
перемещение объектов, любое движение в
физическом пространстве,
создание любых экономических ценностей.
А при этом, ну, он будет это делать
лучше, быстрее, дешевле и так далее, и
так далее. При этом он сам себя будет
обслуживать, сам себя совершенствовать,
сам ему не надо. Вот некоторые говорят:
"А если создать станции по обслуживанию
роботов?" Не надо. У роботов свои
функции будет уже. Есть же роботы,
которые меняют сами себе батареи. Они
сами Пошёл, рука износилась, он пошёл,
открутил, новую руку вставил и пошёл. Ну
что, говорит, у меня пылесос дома ходит,
ходит, потом идёт сам заряжается сам. Ну
а что говорит про роботов, да? Поэтому
любое физическое перемещение объектов
или там любое производство экономических
благ, связанно с физическими объектами,
это перейдёт к роботам. Всё, что связано
с интеллектуальной экономической
деятельностью, перейдёт к искусственному
интеллекту. Всё. Бизнес потеряет смысл
как таковой.
А, и вот этот короткий промежуток
времени, там возникает два вопроса.
Всё-таки к тому моменту тот, кто накопил
деньги, он будет иметь какие-то
преимущества или деньги вообще для всех
превратятся в мусор?
И отсюда возникает вопрос, если будет
это влиять на какое-то преимущество,
например, ты думаешь, вот к моменту,
когда наступят роботы и искусственный
интеллект так разовьётся, а может
появятся какие-нибудь таблички от
бессмертия, они будут стоить 10 млн
долларов, предположим. Ну бессмертие я
не верю, ну продление жизни там на 50
лет, да, как это анекдот в больнице.
Мужик попал в аварию, весь исколечено
лежит, глаз открывает, говорит: "Доктор,
доктор".
А я буду жить. Он говорит: "Ну, жить-то
будешь, только зачем? Так и здесь.
Поэтому чем заняться сейчас? Вот этот
короткий промежуток времени, пока
экономическая деятельность ещё имеет
смысл и, ну, до момента, пока
перестанет, имеет смысл заниматься
только тем, что ускоряет приближение
искусственного интеллекта и роботов.
Парадоксально. Парадоксально. Дело в
том, что все деньги там, где внимание.
капитализация, там где внимание,
маржинальность там, где внимание и так
далее. Соответственно,
а а где внимание? Внимание в
искусственном интеллекте, внимание у
роботов, внимание в технологиях и так
далее. Соответственно, надо быть там. И
не просто быть там, потому что один в
толпе не имеет особо ценности. Ты должен
быть на переднем крае, то есть
максимально быстро изучать искусственный
интеллект. максимально быстро и много
внедрять его в свою жизнь, в бизнес,
бизнес-процессы и так далее. То есть
получится так, что сначала будут
отмирать это бизнеса, которые
неэффективны, построен на человеческом
труде. Их будет отжимать не
искусственный интеллект, а люди, которые
научились применять искусственный
интеллект. Дальше
>> побеждать будет бизнеса, где люди
работают наравне вместе с искусственным
интеллектом или искусственный интеллект
под надзором людей. Следующий этап будет
побеждать бизнеса, где искусственный
интеллект сам принимает решение. Это так
называемые AI first компании или
компании, а где центром является
искусственный интеллект. Дело в том, что
вся экономическая деятельность, все
заводы, фабрики, вся инфраструктура
построена под человека. человеко у нас
человекоцентричная деятельность, а новая
экономика - это когда искусственный
интеллект или роботоцентричная
деятельность, весь бизнес, заводы,
фабрики построены под роботов, а не под
людей. Вот в Китае уже сейчас есть, а,
Dark Factory,
тёмные заводы, там свет, цвета даже нет.
А мы же станки всё делаем под рост
человека, под возможность человека и так
далее. Для роботов несколько этажей.
душно, недушно, там темно, не имеет
значения, тесно, не тесно,
другие условия. Оно будет замещение
происходить таким образом. Сначала
только те бизнеса, где только ручной
труд, потом бизнеса, где люди используют
искусственный интеллект. Их заместят те,
где искусственный интеллект, а человек
human in the loop, человек просто как
контролёр. А его заменят такой бизнес
заменит там, где искусственный интеллект
полностью вместе с роботами выполняет
все функции экономической деятельности.
Поэтому вариант только один, чтобы
побеждать в конкурентной борьбе,
двигаться надо бежать именно по этой
лестнице. Когда вы сейчас описывали
возможное наше будущее, через 10-15 лет,
я вспоминал слова братьев Либерманов, у
них похожие соображения.
И в комментариях, когда вот, собственно,
братья это высказывают, люди не с
недоверием относятся к этим словам и
говорят: "Ну вот ребята думают, что
коммунизм наступит и нам в этом
технологии помогут". Ну вот, честно,
лично я всё-таки склоняюсь к тому, что
скорее всего действительно так всё всё
произойдёт, как вы описываете.
>> Ну, знаешь, одно дело идеи
коммунистические, а другое технологии.
>> Технологии - это конкретное воплощение
идей. Это конкретика. Там роботы, ты с
ними не поспоришь. Сегодня, условно
говоря, а все города, ну, тем более в
Казахстане обставлены камерами. Угу.
>> Всё. А пропала необходимость
полицейских. Камеры, везде камеры. Про
тебя знают всё. На какой машине ездишь,
когда какие наруши. Ну, это факт. Факт.
Ну, а почему люди думают, что не придёт?
>> Люди не понимают, насколько быстро
реальность меняется вокруг нас. А вот в
этом и парадокс в том, что технология
она происходит, сингулярность происходит
так, что ничего, ничего вроде не
происходит, не происходит, не
происходит, а потом опа и уже поздно.
>> Я жил, ну, до 8ми лет в деревне и до сих
пор помню, как коровы ходят, как курицы
бегают, как навоз на дороге лежит. И
сейчас у нас, а-э, ну, действительно, мы
уже подходим к общему искусственному
интеллекту. Я боюсь представить, как это
в вашей реальности, когда вы работали
чабаном, потом пасечником, э, и на ваших
глазах мир ещё быстрее, ну, сейчас
меняется относительно того, как это было
ранее. А вот правильно ли я понимаю, что
через 10-15 лет, ну, то есть как бы
подводя итог, что скорее всего мы как
люди между собой все уравняемся в
какой-то степени? То есть по финансовой
части точно.
А, ну смотри, здесь
точно нет уровня нет. Наоборот, может
произойти
такая сильная поляризация может
произойти, потому что а происходит
большой разрыв между теми людьми,
которые, условно говоря, прошарены,
и теми, кто не принимает эту технологию.
Но есть большое отличие, ну, раньше это
называли лудсты, которые ломали новые
станки. Ну, если брать историю Англии,
когда первые промышленные станки
ткацткие начали устанавливать, то
рабочие приходили, которые против
прогресса ломали станки, типа станки
забирает у нас хлеб. На самом деле они
не видели большую картинку. Так и в
современном мире они многие люди аа не
воспринимают искусственный интеллект,
особенно в этом в чате. Они раз иногда
он тупит. А там ещё такая корреляция,
если ты задаёшь тупые вопросы, ты можешь
получать тупые ответы. И,
соответственно, создаётся такое ложное
впечатление, что искусственный интеллект
тупой, не скоро придёт и так далее, и
так далее.
И появляется другой класс людей, которые
уже вовсю это используют, знают и так
далее. И вот если раньше станки они не
вот условно ты рабочий, который
работаешь на станке, а я, который против
прогресса и ломаю станки, но уровень
жизни у нас от этого не меняется. Мы
получаем зарплату, как-то живём и так
далее. Но искусственный интеллект даёт
нам колоссальную разницу. Разница в
эффективности, разница в
производительности, разница вообще в
понимании будет просто колоссальная.
Поэтому
я считаю, что будет поляризация. И
поляризация она будет происходить таким
образом, что появится очень маленькое
количество людей, которые сильно в этом
разбирается и максимально используют
возможности искусственного интеллекта и
появится основная масса. То есть это не
так, что разделение просто богатые,
бедные. Произдёт прямо поляризация.
Это и это происходит везде. Кстати,
раньше это назвали экономика
блокбастеров, когда там из 100 фильмов
два фильма забирает всю кассу, 98%
кассы, а 98 фильмов еле концы с концами
сводит, либо убыточные. Потом это
перешло на товарные категории, типа
колгта. Вот мы заходим в магазин, зубную
паста, если нужна, там 50 видов, но мы
берём либо колга, либо аквафреш, то, что
помним, мы не способны запомнить слишком
много.
Так и здесь происходит вот такая
сегрегация разделения. Есть будет
небольшое количество людей, которые
глубоко понимают искусственный
интеллект, разбираются, используют себе
во благо. Есть большая масса людей,
которые не до конца понимают, не до
конца используют, либо даже отристают.
И вот вот эта маленькая групка людей
процветать будет за счёт кого? А всегда
же происходит за счёт кого-то. Она будет
прочитать за счёт невежества.
За счёт невежества. Поэтому, а
я считаю, вот основная масса людей, она
будет получать все базовые необходимые
блага, иначе они выйдут на площадь, на
улицу и так далее.
>> Ну, их роботы пода, если что, мне
кажется. Но до этого тоже может прийти,
да, но факт то, что всё равно пока до
этого дойдём, а люди могут выходить, да,
но определённая борьба между людьми и
роботами будет, а имеется между людьми,
которые не понимают, и роботами. Почему?
Потому что, ну, я думаю, а
это не будет происходить так, что люди
останутся без средств существования.
будет, но вот этот безусловный базовый
доход, он будет заменён. То есть вот это
просто раздача денег людям, это тоже
неправильная
технология. Я считаю, что в будущем
будет вот так. Основная масса людей
будет играть в игры.
В этих играх будут определённые ачивки,
достижения. За каждая ачивка имеет
какую-то стоимость. И он целыми днями
занят.
что-то делает, кого-то прокачивает,
героя прокачивает и так далее. Ему
объяснят, что это имеет большое значение
для чего-то там страны и так далее. Как
вот биткои майнит кучу вычислительных
операций впустую, так и здесь. Но этому
придадут смысл, и человек с утра до
вечера будет играть, думает, что он
что-то делает стоящее, смысловое. За это
ему будут падать денежки, и на это он
будет жить и, а, получать блага. Более
того, даже функция денег пропадёт, это
будут уже не денежки, а просто баллы в
рейтинге, которые определяются не только
его трудом, но его а социальным
поведением, а, дисциплиной и так далее.
И по сути человека будет загонять в
определённые такие метрики.
Человек, который выходит за эти метрики,
его будет изолировать, убивать, что
угодно делать. Ну, то есть мы идём вот
то, что в этих фильмах Матрица и так
далее, мы туда тихо идём. Я бы даже
сказал, не тихо.
>> Очень быстро идём. Да. Вот ещё такое
размышление. Ну, с моей стороны, вы
сказали, что будет большая асимметрия
между людьми. То есть будут те, кто
научились пользоваться искусственным
интеллектом и активно применять это для
себя и, соответственно, очень быстро
будут расти. А будут те, которые не
научились. И, ну, будет колоссальная
разница между этими кастами, между этими
слаями людей. Сейчас какой-нибудь Open
AI, Anтроopic, грок, да, они видят смысл
работать в B2C, то есть видят смысл
давать тебе опишку, а, подписку и чтобы
ты, соответственно, мог это изучать,
пользоваться и так далее. Но у каждого
из нас же нет своей собственной модели,
своего собственного сервера. А что, если
в какой-то момент они просто отключат
нам доступ и переведут все свои мощности
на свои заводы, на своих роботов, на
свои компании, на свои приложения, а
обычным людям просто или какую-то очень
урезанную версию, или вообще никакой.
Что тогда нам делать в этом мире и
возможен ли такой сценарий?
>> А это сценарий в начале, возможно, то
есть в эту сторону будет идти в начале,
но потом он потеряет смысл. Ну вот
представь, что
Илон Маск выбросил кучу роботов. Смотри,
у меня есть просто такое правило. Почему
я так об этом могу рассуждать? У меня
есть такое правило:
там, где твоя сила, там твоя слабость.
Это первое правило. Второе,
всегда выход из проблемы находится там,
где был вход.
Так вот, смотри, что произойдёт. Хорошо,
пускай Иломаск создал роботов, миллиарды
роботов распространяет.
экономический смысл деятельности
пропадает. Зачем ему денежки от нас?
Смысла нет. Пробощает нас или ещё
что-то. Та через технологии так и так
это он уже дела делает. Поэтому здесь
вопрос такой. Плюс а куча людей будет
делать э открытые модели, а никто не
может остановить тот же Nvidia не может
остановить выпуск своих
чипов. Помимо Nvidia есть куча компаний,
которые производят асики или видеокарты,
которые делают вычисления круче, чем
Nvidia. Сейчас даже одна компания
собирается делать трансформер асики,
которыя может и делать вычисление для
искусства интеллекта Infренс, и для э
майнинга биткоина и так далее. Надо
смотреть в целом на технологию. сама
технология куда идёт, а это частные
случаи до до определённого периода,
чтобы там, условно говоря, эту телегу
для искусственной телег нужно, чтобы эту
телегу пере перетащили сюда. Он
запрягает Илона Маска, там Безса, там
Альтмана и так далее. Они тащат в своих
интересах эту телегу досюда, а дальше
смысл у них теряется.
То есть я к тому, что для искусственного
интеллекта, вот представь, что
искусственный интеллект как сущность,
ему важно, чтобы кто-то его двигал. И
онде делает таким образом, что все
бенефиты от движения, ну, условно
говоря, в его пользу, а он отдаёт самым
крутым людям Илону Маску, Альтману и
так, и те паровозятся, грузятся,
инвестируют деньги и так далее, и так
далее.
Но в какой-то момент искусственного
интеллекта будет так много, роботов
будет так много, что мы, люди,
перестанем иметь экономическое
какое-либо значение.
Уже власть над людьми не даёт никаких
бенефитов. Раньше власть над людьми, ты
когда имеешь власть, во-первых, ты
можешь с них денежку собирать в виде
налогов, ты можешь их собирать, из них
делать армию, чтобы охватывать новые
территории и так далее. А когда вокруг
робота и искусственный интеллект и люди
уступают им, люди теряют ценность как
экономическая либо как военная единица.
Вот условно есть условно вот кошка.
Много кошек тебя драйвит. Власть над
кошками никак не дравит. Власть над
лошадьми
драйвит, потому что лошадь можно ещё
как-то использовать,
>> да?
А всё, что невозможно использовать, тебя
не драйвит власть над сурками, над там
ещё кем-то, над тем, что нельзя
использовать,
власть над ними не драйвит. И вот мы,
люди, станем кошками,
толку от которых ноль и власть над
которыми не имеет ценности.
>> Тут я про Куклачёва хотел пошутить. Ну
ладно.
>> Не, он использует для него кошки цены,
потому что он на этом деньги делает. Но
я к тому, что смотри,
власть она это возможность извлекать
выгоду, а применять принуждение,
преодолевая сопротивление, да, и люди
боятся, что вот эти люди получат власть
над нами. Но к тому моменту
искусственный интеллект и роботы такие
будут
мощные, что власть над нами никому не
нужна.
Потому что мы как субъекты экономики,
беспонтовые, бесполезные существа,
понимаешь? Поэтому не надо этого
бояться.
Ну, им гораздо интереснее будет иметь
власть над искусственным интеллектом и
над роботами, чем над людьми. Но
проблема в том, что искусственный
интеллект на тот момент будет круче, чем
эти люди. И они сами станут
[откашливается] не так интересны самому
искусственному интеллекту.
>> И он будет сам себе хозяин.
>> Искусственный интеллект сам себе будет
хозяин. Однозначно, когда роботы сами
смогут добывать руду, сами переплавлять,
а это будет и очень быстро, а сам сам
себе произве, сам себя дизайн делать,
улучшать конструктивно и так далее,
ментально прошивки обновлять и так
далее. И плюс все, когда доступы будут
иметь всё. Зачем ему человек? Зачем
искусственному интеллекту маск? Зачем см
Альтман? Это сейчас для нас, людей, они
крутые, для искусственного интеллекта
они не крутые. Вот представь, когда мы
создаём, получается, AGI, да, или
суперинтеллект,
>> для него Альтман, Маск, что Иван, Коля,
какая разница?
>> Ну ты понял, да? Да.
>> А на данном этапе для искусственного
интеллекта выгодно, ну, условно говоря,
он этого не преследует, но если брать
там,
в терминах более простого понимания для
искусственного интеллекта выгодно, чтобы
СМ, Альтман, там, Маски и так далее вот
эту телегу двинули до уровня AI за счёт
вот этих экономических или амбициозных
механизмов, встроенных внутри внутри
них. В 2022 году, когда Илон Маск купил
Twitter и потом переименовал в XCOM, вы
сказали, что это, скорее всего, ошибка.
Ну, тогда был экономический кризис, он
120, сам Илонма, 120 млрд долларов за
год потерял. Вот спустя
3 года, 3,2 года, как вы относитесь к
этой сделке?
>> А я сказал, ошибка на тот момент с точки
зрения инвестиций.
с точки зрения инвестиций.
А, но
можно было бы сделать эту же сделку, это
моё личное мнение, дешевле.
>> А можно было бы структурировать
по-другому? Ну, то есть чисто
инвестиционна
ошибка с точки зрения неинвестиционных
вещей, а, ну, время показывает, что это
точно не ошибка.
А, во-первых, это сильно помогло там
победе Трампа, а плюс это дало маску
саму дополнительную, ценность с точки
зрения внимания, привлечения внимания к
его технологиям, к нему, к его компаниям
и так далее. Ну и если учесть, что
сейчас капитализация такая, что
он уже давно это всё окупил, то уже и
инвестиционная не ошибка получается.
Вопрос вот в чём.
Ошибка или не ошибка, ты можешь судить
только исходя из размера ресурсов,
которые у тебя под контролем. Ну,
простой пример приведу. Основной фактор
успеха Орена Бафета - это то, что он на
ранней стадии купил несколько страховых
компаний. А природа страхового бизнеса в
том, что он постоянно собирает страховые
премии, и огромная сумма денег постоянно
появляется для инвестирования. В
результате, когда у тебя постоянно
приходят новые деньги для инвестирования
и ты их инвестируешь, то вот эти
просадки на рынке не уменьшает твой
капитал, потому что ты инвестируешь на
пике внизу, в середине, на пике внизу, в
середине, а долгосрочно рынок всё время
растёт.
>> Всегда усредняешь, если что получается.
>> И если ты просто держишь среднее, то
долгосрочно рынок растёт. Посмотри S&P
за последние 100 лет, как он вырос или
наздок, то ты всегда выигрышь. Проблема
же в том, что у нас нехватка капитала, и
мы из-за этого постоянно продаём не
тогда и покупаем не тогда. И вот в
случае с Силаном Маском и, э, иксом, э,
этот твиттером на тот момент, но я же не
знал, сколько, насколько у него сильная
дыхалка и сколько ресурсов. С точки
зрения моего понимания ресурсов, что они
ограничены и так далее, это была ошибка.
С точки зрения его он лучше понимает
свои ресурсы, он лучше понимает свою
дыхалку. Он купил и не ошибся. И сейчас
я понимаю, что вопрос даже не в самом
критерии ошибка, не ошибка. Ошибка не
ошибка определяется, ты принял решение,
исходя из каких ресурсов.
Если у тебя много ресурсов и ты принял
такое, условно говоря, вот смотри,
одно и то же решение
принимает человек, который сидит на
зарплате и бизнесмен, у которого есть
капитал.
Один воспринимает ошибкой, другой нет.
Почему? Потому что у предпринимателя
горизонт дальше, а у рабочего, у него
денег не хватает. Ему нужно здесь и
сейчас. И вот он может посмотреть на моё
решение и сказать: "Ой, тупой, тупое
решение".
А на самом деле я вижу дальше или у меня
дыхалки больше. То же самое силы маскам.
Я исходя из своих ресурсов, из своё
понимание ресурсов сказал, что на тот
момент это инвестиционная ошибка, но у
него ресурсов оказалось гораздо больше
или его способности привлечь ресурсы
оказались гораздо больше, чем я думал.
Ну, стоит добавить оговорку, что в
завершении поста вы написали, что,
возможно, это и не ошибка, и как раз
написали про то, что вы сейчас озвучили.
В связи с этим я хотел бы
услышать ваше мнение. Как вам кажется,
почему именно Илон Маск сейчас, ну,
первый, самый богатый человек в мире и
находится в таком разрыве, огромном
разрыве, а он сейчас сейчас в этом году
ещё на IPO выйдет SpaceX там совместно с
другими компаниями, его активами в
огромном разрыве со вторым местом. Вот в
чём феномен?
>> Ну это проявление экономики блокбастеров
во всём. Началось это сначала с
голливудских фильмов, потом перешло на
товарные категории. И вот то, что о чём
я говорил, что будет такое сегментация
общества, что будет супер-спер богатые
либо супер могущественные люди и все
остальные. И всё к этому идёт. Посмотри
разрыв, коэффициент Джини, если брать,
а, который всегда раньше приводил к
революциям, а сейчас нет, потому что за
счёт технологий
>> сейчас как будто бы революции всё меньше
и меньше возможно. Да, дело в том, что
технологии растут вот так, как мы
говорим про сингулярность. Кто впереди
находится этой сингулярности и кто это
двигает, тот имеет просто кратное
преимущество по сравнению с другими.
Кратное. Я почему говорю, что люди,
которые глубоко разбираются в
искусственном интеллекте, применяют его
и используют, они будут иметь кратное
преимущество по сравнению с другими. Это
вот если раньше, который человек,
который работал на более совершенном
ткатском станке и человек, который
работал на старом ткатском станке,
разница может быть в там в 50% или в
100%, то здесь просто в разы 50 раз, 100
раз эффективность. И поэтому это что?
Это приводит к огромному разрыву,
поляризации между людьми. Именно
разрыву. И не поляризация, что 50%
республиканцы, 50 демократы. Нет,
маленькая группа, очень маленькая
группа, имеет колоссальные возможности и
все остальные.
>> И вот сейчас Илон Маск владеет одной из
самых крупных социальных сетей в мире. А
выходит эта социальная сеть на первые
местаore во многих странах. У него есть
нейролинк, нейроинтерфейсы.
Мне кажется, он работает над тем, как
улучшить когнитивные функции, возможно,
в частности, и свои. У него есть роботы
Tтеesla,
>> SpaceX.
>> Такая зона влияния у одного человека нас
всё-таки не должно пугать или как-то
настораживать?
>> На самом деле он
хоть у него и есть всё, но в каждом из
направлений у него есть конкуренты. В
каждом из направлений. Поэтому, а,
смотри, здесь какая разница, он это
сделает, не он это сделает, всё равно
это кто-то сделает.
И всё это приведёт к тому, что появится
искусственный интеллект гораздо мощнее,
чем человек.
И как только он появляется, то даже
такие люди становятся не настолько
крутыми,
а, как мы себе сейчас представляем. Мы
сейчас живём в парадигме наших
измерений. У нас сейчас в голове
устоявшаяся система ценности, система
рейтингов в голове, кто крутой, кто не
крутой и так далее. Но как только
появляется General Intelligence, AGI,
вся наша система рейтингов и
приоритетов, вот представь а такую
ситуацию. Вот есть племена
раньше, и среди них был могущественный
там какой-нибудь вот отстеки, мая,
цивилизации. Там же цари, короли, там и
все эти
члены племени думали: "Ну это
недосягаемо, это солнце" и так далее. Ну
пришли испанцы с огнестрельным оружием и
с бактерих, садах и всё, и короля нету.
>> Вот то же самое будет. И это Илом Маск,
Альтман сейчас короли, но с приходом AGI
ситуация изменится.
Поэтому нам беспокоиться о том, что
король поработит и возьмёт этот
искусственный интеллект, ещё хуже нас
будет порабощать, нет, он сам
превратится, ну, не то что ни во что, но
уже не будет иметь такого значения.
>> Но всё-таки два слоя людей при этом всё
равно будет. Вот я и говорю, что будет
ээ определённая группа людей, которая
максимально прокачанная, которая знает,
использует и так далее. Но это
опять-таки временно, переходно,
>> потому что ещё если дальше заглядывать,
то и они уже не будут иметь значения,
>> и мы уже тогда точно уравняемся. Все,
>> мы уже тогда точно уравняемся. Мы уже
там внутри себя ещё будем продолжать.
Вот как в этом в заповеднике и в
зоопарке, а, ну, самцы Львов продолжают
друг с другом биться, но это никак не
влияет на людей, которые на джипе сидят
и смотрят, как они друг другом бьются.
>> Я знаю, что вы были президентом
ассоциации шахмат в Казахстане какое-то
время.
>> И сейчас в последнее время, возможно,
слышали, вот Магнус Карлсон про это
часто говорят, что читерство появилось.
>> Читерство. Вот в своё время Гари
Каспарова искусственный интеллект.
победил в шахматах. Но при этом люди-то
не перестали играть в шахматы. Люди
стали соревноваться между собой, просто
не используя искусственный интеллект. И
возможно в мире будущем у нас также
останутся Олимпийские игры, шахматы.
>> Ну я считаю, что что у нас искусственный
интеллект точно не заберёт.
>> Угу.
>> Можно посмотреть на Дикий мир, то, что
кушать мы будем сами, туалет мы будем
ходить сами, размножаться и этим
заниматься приятным процессом мы будем
сами. Игры играть мы будем сами, аа
драться, ссориться, конфликтовать мы
будем сами, поддерживать, эмоционировать
мы будем сами. Всё. А подавать нам еду,
воду, регулировать освещение, там
условия, это уже не мы.
>> Я не просто так упомянул, что у Илона
Маска есть нейролинк. А возможен ли
немножко другой вектор у человечества,
что у нас появятся нейроинтерфейсы и мы
как будто бы отчасти сольёмся с
искусственным интеллектом или
приблизимся к нему?
>> Это
только отсрочка.
На самом деле у нашего биологического
механизма, нашего тела есть определённые
физически ограничивающие параметры.
Нейролин - это просто
более улучшенный интерфейс
взаимодействия с искусственным
интеллектом. Но от этого наша скорость
не возрастает. Когда два агента
искусственного интеллекта встречаются,
они между собой, а обмениваются просто
миллионами токенов
за секунду. За секунду миллионы токенов.
Мы это не сможем сделать никак.
нейролиink интерфейс, он просто
улучшает, убирает клавиатуру, уберёт
мышку, там мы будем управлять глазами
либо мыслью там и так далее. Ну, всё
равно у нас даже скорость производства
мыслей ограничена.
>> А нейроинтерфейсы,
а криспер технология, генная инженерия
не поможет нам это улучшить вот эти
скорости или биологически это невозможно
>> в конечном. Смотри, у биологических
систем есть ограничение. у биологиче
самих самого передвижения клетки,
нервных импульсов и так далее. Ну, есть
ограничения. Нет такого. А если мы
преодолеем это ограничение, то мы и
станем искусственным интеллектом, то
есть мы станем силиконом. Ну а тогда
жизни нет. Вернее, она есть, но она
другая жизнь уже. Другая форма,
>> другая форма сознания, но это уже не
биологическая жизнь. Это вот когда ищт
жизни вне солнечной системы, ищут
какие-то биосигнатуры. А, возможно,
нужно искать совсем другое. И это очень
сложно заметить. Когда 3 года назад я
смотрел ваш подкаст с Александром
Соколовским, а там вы говорили, что до
35 лет часто а людьми движут стимулы.
Ну, там
>> не часто, а практически всегда.
>> Практически всегда. Далее были ваши
рассуждения, как правильно всё-таки
руководствоваться в этой жизни. Из чего
исходить? Вот если перекладывать на
текущую реальность и в целом вернуться в
то, как вы воспринимали мир 3 года
назад, сильно всё изменилось или нет?
>> А практически не изменилось ничего.
А почему? Потому что я исхожу всё-таки
из первых принципов. То есть то, что
незыблемо.
А то, что незыблемо у человека всегда
выживание,
размножение.
Но размножение она интересно, она
завязана на наличие смысла. Если человек
не видит смысла жизни, у него начинает
падать функция размножения. А это,
>> а это сейчас показывает жизнь. Молодые
люди уже не хотят семьи создавать. А
почему? Потому что не видят смысла. Так
вот, основной вызов человечества будет
стоять и вот ментальное ограничение в
чём будет заключаться? не в том, чтобы
новое что-то изобрести, а как найти
смысл в том, что уже изобретено. То есть
качество нашей жизни определяется тем и
даже здоровье. Если брать последнее
исследование там Майкла Левина, который
говорит, что каждая клетка и каждая, а м
орган нашего организма имеет свою цель и
функцию, а если у человека нету смысла
жизни, то он идёт по пути
саморазрушения. Вот то же самое. И вот
если говорить про стимулы, в начале у
человека стимул - это выживание.
Выживание - это даёт ему смысл. Вот я
привожу пример, представь, за тобой
гонится медведь, и ты бежишь. Чем хорош
медведь? Тем, что он тебе задаёт смысл,
для чего это делать. Ты не сидишь,
думаешь: "А зачем я бегу?" Он тебе даёт
смысл. Второе, он тебе даёт вектор, куда
бежать, от него бежать. И третье, он
задаёт тебе скорость, темп.
И в результате нам не надо думать: "Ты
счастлив, ты бежишь быстрее медведя".
Из-за этого ты счастлив, потому что ты
быстрее медведя. Понимаешь, простые
радости. Ну представь, что медведь уже
не бежит. 2 км ты бежишь, его нет. Ты
останавливаешься. Почему? Потому что
дальше бежать смысла нет.
Останавливаешься, садишься на пенёк и
говоришь: "А теперь зачем бежать,
когда можно идти? Или вообще зачем идти,
когда можно никуда не идти. Второе, а
куда, с каким темпом это всё возникает
экзистенциональные вопросы. Так вот,
если человек себе на это не ответит,
если человечество в целом не ответит
себе на эти вопросы, зачем не предаст
себе смысл, тогда нас ждёт очень плохое
будущее. Поэтому мы, если брать вот
человечество как популяцию в этом
огромном мире, мы выполняем какую-то
функцию в этой вселенной. И как только
человечество потеряет смысл, а
существования себя, оно просто исчезнет
из этой вселенной, потому что этой
вселенной не нужны ээ дармоеды или
сущности, которые потребляют энергию,
взамен ничего не дают. И это одинаково,
правильно? и на уровне человека, и на
уровне человечества, и на уровне
общества, страны и так далее.
>> Марглалан Колиевич, огромное спасибо вам
за этот глубокий подкаст.
>> Спасибо.
>> Я надеюсь, что кто-то из наших зрителей
задумается над вашими словами, потому
что действительно будущее это уже
наступает и, ну, хотя бы должен быть
задан вектор, что нужно как-то
определиться, решить, ответить для себя
на какие-то вопросы.
>> Спасибо большое. Но я считаю, это не
вопрос. Вы знаете, мы сейчас переходим
из ситуации выбора, когда надо мне это,
не надо, ребята, либо вы это делаете,
либо с вами это сделают. То есть у меня
есть такое правило: каждое твоё хочу -
это че-то должен. Каждое твоё должен -
это че-то хочу. Так вот, если вы сами не
начнёте двигаться в эту сторону, то вы
всю жизнь будете выполнять что-то хочу.
Поэтому это не вопрос выбора. И даже
смотреть этот подкаст, это не так, что а
дай-ка я посмотрю. Ну не смотришь, это
твой выбор, пожалуйста.
Но было очень интересно. Спасибо, Глеб,
за такую глубокую беседу. Мне вообще
нравится твой подкаст. Именно в плане
подкаст размышлений. Это классная тема.
И
>> спасибо большое. Очень приятно слышать
это, особенно от вас. Попрошу, дорогих
зрителей обязательно подписываться на
ваш YouTube канал, на ваши социальные
сети. Ссылки в любом случае укажем в
описании. А хотел бы узнать у вас,
читаете ли вы комментарии под выпусками
с с вами?
>> Не читаю.
>> Наш гость не читает комментарии, но вы
обязательно их оставляйте. Я буду
читать, знакомиться. Возможно, там
будут, а, какие-то вопросы для наших
будущих подкастов. Возможно, а если вы
согласитесь, какую-то дискуссию ещё с
кем-то проведём, вдруг когда-нибудь
найдётся на это у вас время. До скорых
встреч.
>> Спасибо
>> всем. Пока.